welcome to the news at noon everyone i'm
alex backus look at that
several areas across the valley woke up
to snow this morning look at those
rooftops
this is drone video we shot this morning
around lone mountain
beautiful we are tracking all of this
winter weather with team coverage hope
you've gotten out to enjoy it a bit
bianca holmen is live in summerlin with
how people are enjoying the snow today
but first let's go to nate sannebaum for
what we can expect the rest of the
afternoon hi nate
good afternoon alex from the bowtie nate
home studio what a morning it was and
it's still a chilly one out there we
have a live picture from our camera at
red rock resort looking out to the south
and to the west you can see the 215
underneath there
let's get the official numbers out there
for you from mccarran international
we'll check your neighborhoods here in a
few minutes
42 degrees wow 62
humidity still some moisture we are one
degree warmer than we were at this time
24 hours ago
and the storm system is literally
rolling right on out of here we still
have some cloud cover
and we can't completely rule out a
chance for maybe a sprinkle later this
evening
so let's get your weather headlines for
the most part the storms are moving on
you've got to have snow tires and chains
to get up to mount charleston there may
be some other problems up there that
we'll talk about
next chance for rain will be thursday
night into friday and it's all coming up
in our brand new eight news now
eight day forecast alex all right nate
thank you
we'll see you then but we also want to
let you know right now that lee canyon
road is currently closed in both
directions so be sure to follow 8 news
now for the latest traffic updates and
weather impacts but that came out just
about an hour ago
in the meantime several areas have been
getting snow since just
after midnight bianca holman live from
fox hill park
on the far west side i was just out
there with my dog bianca it was
beautiful how's it looking
we rarely get snow here often so folks
definitely wanted to take advantage
of what came down this morning here at
far hill park
there was a large crowd that gathered in
the snow to
of course experience the snow globe
experience here are some pictures and
video from other parts of town
in the northwest valley snow was
everywhere coating the trees covering
the ground
the flurries didn't stop joggers or
early morning commuters from making
their way out
cynthia gainey the organizer of vegas
strong 5k sent us these pictures
that were taken on the 215 between
cheyenne and lone mountain
she says they got up to three inches of
snow
we even got pictures from our friends
down in pahrump drivers having
to clear their windshields of snow
before heading off and then our
four-legged friends
dogs playing in the white powder pam and
brett haynes and parum sent these
pictures of their dog frank enjoying the
early morning snow
it's been really nice i just like going
down the hills and sledding
it's really cool i've lived in las vegas
my whole life it doesn't snow here often
so that was a mom and daughter you saw
us speak
[Music]
gear they said this was their second
time out to the park on this snow day
now we as you can see and as you've
noticed the snow is going to be melting
here soon
so definitely send us your pictures and
video to our facebook page instagram and
twitter
reporting from summerlin bianca holmen 8
news now